[Music]
have you guys seen the movie knives out
I've been meaning to be so good wait
we're talking about knives outside
shouts a knives out
wait what's that it's a movie oh is it
like it's like a whodunit movie bond is
starring in it who bond James Daniel
Craig yeah Craig [ __ ] get out
yeah get out Wow
True Lies is in it too James Bond get
Captain America's in it
mission impossible isn't it wait no I
don't even know what it know what it is
I just want to throw out a title I
really don't know what it is
nice um well full speed but you said you
know what it is I was trying to eat over
the top I'm like stop it okay the reason
why we're talking about this movie is
because I am about to spoil it for you
wait no why why no I haven't seen a No
see me yeah take five are you for real I
want to see it wait Alfred Danny no i
legit don't want to know well let me
know I'll forget it as Tiger would say
and it's not I haven't seen this movie
either just as bummed as you guys
because well mother watches applied on
the watch it director his name is ryan
johnson this is what Apple Rihanna Ryan
Ryan is this about Apple it is okay so
we can we do this without spoiling no
first I gotta say it though okay
I can't do what they'll support okay say
it do it I know the story okay maybe you
could do without spoiling it then the
director even said this quote I don't
know if I should say this or not Apple
they let you use iPhones and movies but
bad guys cannot have iPhones on in
camera like on camera yeah so throughout
this whole movie okay cuz Casey's seen
this so bad guys could only have [ __ ]
like
they can't have an iPhone on hand you
have an Android or some [ __ ] there's a
way to do this without spoiling him so
she just did used to himself he said
himself well
oh now every single filmmaker that has a
bad guy in their movie that's supposed
to be a secret wants to murder me it's
going to screw me on the next mystery
movie that I write that's all I gotta
say
there you go just use a samsung I see
you yeah because he's sponsored by Apple
right I guess well I guess the spoiler
is this right it's because if the bad
guy can't have an iPhone then it for
what is it if you're watching a movie
then you just deduct it but at spoilers
for all movies pretty much you can
deduct with the bad guy as if it's a
whodunit right wow dude Apple everyone
can watch mafia on Jamie [ __ ] party
then cuz we had iPhones [ __ ] you can't
control us Tim Cook either camera Tim
Cook what are you thinking that's [ __ ]
up yeah it didn't cook you know want Tim
Cook they don't want Apple to see seem
like bad guy Tim Cook how come when I
buy a download $75 what's the doctor
down to anything at Apple like like an
attachment like hey cool you about an
apple laptop guess what we don't have
HDMI on your laptop anymore so now you
gotta get a dongle now it feels so $5
just doing those things to make a little
extra cash there it's a stuffs becoming
more universal oh really geo cuz I'm
pretty sure they're about to have it so
that you can't even plug in your power
cord with a picture like that but okay
fine I'll follow your [ __ ] future
prediction you dumb bull what if they
have no more attachments that would be
nice no more don't y'all getting that
it's actually so annoying because I have
the new laptop and now like just to plug
in my SD card I need a [ __ ] dongle
it's like you're [ __ ] member when we
all had Game Boys you had to get the
[ __ ] magnifying glass and [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] why did they add that extra
piece of inconvenience
yeah they took everything out there's no
CD slot there's I mean I think you said
earlier they're making [ __ ] and killing
on this on the little little dog
money to not put it on the lift but I do
appreciate it we'll say money they save
space so they can make it thinner and
smaller more like weight but no that's
what the [ __ ] right if Steve Jobs
was here he'd be like you don't need to
[ __ ] hook up your computer like it's
neo in the goddamn matrix oh look at how
pretty this looks
oh I mean I love my laptop but I miss
this no I just want an HDMI port you
gotta get the dongle and plug it into
this [ __ ] oh right oh hey congrats Tim
now you're on an airplane you want to
plug in some [ __ ]
you're gonna hope it doesn't wiggle too
much or it's disconnecting a harddrive
cuz I bought a little thingy for the
[ __ ] thingy yeah then I can't even
touch it exactly
charge it which dongle did you get the
stupid dongle yeah you gotta bet a smart
dog we've been used my other one I still
use my old laptop and I bought a new you
don't like that's why I'm a PC [ __ ] you
guys that's how you really edit on your
PC oh yeah I'm a I write on my PC we've
done all of our movies on my people
really how many viruses show the logo
stick on the MSI logo
Wow but no my PC is a 17 inch screen oh
by the way it has more power than
Nikki's laptop currently has and I
bought it five years ago when I paid
1,200 bucks for tupid no it looks sick
well I agree I don't like that it has
red and black on it I just like how oh
my no that's the problem with
quote-unquote gaming PC's or whatever is
they make them look like they're [ __ ]
race cars for some reason they look dumb
I don't need it I just needed the
processing power for editing so I
product what are you editing no I know
you you you can't overpay for it
you win the cool kill seven years my
MacBook Pros five years but don't you
worry about the porn we're gonna be in
the PWR
freedom package it always ties back to
that viruses I don't get viruses because
I [ __ ] devil might support I'll do
this terabytes of coffee for a [ __ ]
month in Vietnam and I swear a
government official hacked my YouTube
yeah because today we're watching
non-stop speeches and Vietnamese content
on YouTube and I was like Warren I had
to change my [ __ ] password and all
that they hacked into my [ __ ] dude and
there's my account it's gone
yes squid oh the tentacle pointed right
wait so how would you have said this
without spoiling it okay
TIFF so you didn't actually take this
one yeah I think that's what I was
worried do you just boil all movies now
but not really you know I'd watch and go
up that's the bad guy you know why
though I watched John wick all this [ __ ]
I don't know what the [ __ ] phones people
are using I knew it as soon as I read
this I'm like why not seeing a [ __ ]
sick ass karate chop or titties I'm not
paying attention usually in movies
really that's a lie you're lying
some waters are okay because I forget
huh yeah
spoilers are okay cuz I forget I will
say I said this before Mad Max fury road
oh yeah I don't watch it yeah I need to
always link so much subtle subtext and
not many titties although there are
there are at the end a lot of titties
there are lots of tits at the end
actually did you enjoy parasite I
oh I'm excited to watch them we watched
care about you come over we bought it I
have the screener mm-hmm well she was
just trying to hang out listen you know
you can rent it online is worth more
than your free screener wait is it get a
dongle and we'll plug it into our new
Mac laptops how come you guys bother
what you didn't like it that much
because we couldn't rent it Casey didn't
like it well he likes it but it's not as
what the [ __ ] movie does Casey like can
we start there all-time is inside Llewyn
Davis [ __ ] is favorite movie because
what about the other one the Coen
brothers won the [ __ ] thing about C's
my favorite movie so good more than all
that here hands down favorite I think so
his hands our favorite is like the most
boring movie what's so good because it's
all about country music if oh that's why
what's the premise is he like country
movie is made for people that say oh I
hate country music well he doesn't like
the country or he says like he likes
like the the [ __ ] story not the
twenty poppy country like the Falklands
yeah at 100 like my grass like old
brother where art thou Bart you watched
it so I watched it and it's made for
people that like to say phrases like
this it's not a movie it's a film yes
so it's bad cuz like to me it's a boring
ass [ __ ] movie but if you put it in
the film category that I guess it's good
for that Oh Mike why you have to be so
pretentious
I think Boogie Nights is also in my
favor thank you what about Goodfellas Oh
what of course it's close I don't know I
don't know you like that
oh my good fellows Wow that's the future
is still top good my favorite yeah mrs.
bulky Doubtfire roll oh yeah was a run
by fruiting I wouldn't say it's my
casino amazing that's my favorite score
says you too by far I'm close this is a
taxi
yeah yeah my favorite movie cuz I or
like favorite color or favorite that's
why I say in the past whatever years
usually because yeah it's hard
Big Lebowski has stood the test of time
for me for 20 [ __ ] clerks one of them
for me clerks yeah how many times we've
watched it though uh a lot communal rats
I [ __ ] like more I love Kevin Smith
and I met him he's awesome
yeah but clerk says very little rewatch
ability for me really yeah yeah I can't
just put it in any time and get in the
mood for clerk I love it I like Kevin
Smith speaking live Ben it's me too me
too and I do like movies when you re
watch it you get more each time
I think chasing amy is Kevin Smith's
best movie ever
I've never seen chasing him it's [ __ ]
great you should watch it legit it's
[ __ ] great I like clerks too because
we're sorry Dawson's hot very good you
know she's came out I didn't know that
yeah she's yeah and did you know that
Cory Booker who was running for
president said that he is her they were
boyfriend and girlfriend and then right
and so so everyone said the haze and
Cory Booker gay cuz apparently did so
now she came out of the lesbian after he
stopped running for president and so
Evans won wait a minute
cory booker why are you ashamed to be
gay corn just be good own that dish
own it own it or he could not see and
she was the one using him oh it could be
bad facts
[Music]